foreign
let's go to Ann Arbor Michigan and talk
to Colin what's up Colin
I'm doing pretty okay I'm uh just
finished up walking with my daughter I
got my second cup of coffee I got my
notebook and uh I'm just really honored
to be here talking to you dude that
sounds like almost the perfect morning
man fantastic so what's up dude
so I'll start with my question I
coming in pretty hot I I survived a
suicide attempt
um about seven years ago
I feel like it connects to me being more
cynical about the world and I want to
change that
hmm
well thanks for calling man
um how many little ones do you have
I just got one I got a baby girl who's
nine months old and it's it's the best
that's cool
um
are you able to talk about what happened
seven years ago
yeah tell me about it
so at the time I was in my
well to give you a quick I'll quickly
tell you where I'm at now I'm 29 been
married for four years I adore my wife I
have this nine month old beautiful baby
girl
um and as we enter our 30s as we
purchase our first home I've I just
don't I'm I'm mostly calling about this
event and my cynicism to hopefully
change my Outlook and not have it rub
off on this sweet baby girl and my wife
um so
I seven years ago I would say honestly
I've had on paper
for the most part a pretty normal
successful uh time as a 20-something so
got my bachelor's degree got my Master's
Degree
um but the kind of blip which I would
say more so is an explosion on that
timeline is this suicide attempt
um
so is Easter morning actually and I at
the time was in a pretty toxic
relationship
um was wrestling some with my face uh I
would say I'm a
strong Christian believer now but
certainly had my time of deconstructing
and reconstructing and all that so that
was pretty hairy and
um just really wrestling this identity
feeling enough
um and that that morning that
relationship ended uh I was actually on
my way to
to church and
decided instead to take a left in my car
go the other way
um find a parking lot
just felt this immense emptiness
and
kind of something you probably don't
hear every day when it comes to suicide
attempts but I I'm a type 1 diabetic
and I just decided to load up on insulin
and try to overdose that way and end
things so now a conventional
you could say message to family and
friends
hey like I just did this uh
and then
kind of went on a drive around town
while my phone blew up
and I was eventually found in a grocery
parking lot still completely conscious
and fine and rushed to the ER and
thankfully before
all of this happened or I guess before
things got bad
uh I should say
they were able to balance out my blood
sugar
um
who can stop me at any time by the way
well I'm just trying to get a a picture
of
trying to listen for how you're telling
the story
[Music]
um
did you have a history of this before
I didn't that's the thing like it was
it's kind of a snap decision
I don't want to hurt anymore I'm sick of
the world and you have a you have an
opportunity right there with you
yeah and did you ever go into a coma I
didn't hear what you said
I the the hospital
for I don't know what happened because
it was so overwhelming but they uh they
they got things fixed and then I was in
a way for
you know a week or so and
have you had any sort of suicidality
since then an idea of of heading out
again
zero okay
so
um you've done a lot of work over the
last few years huh
I have uh yeah I would say I would say
I'm a very introspective reflective guy
um I think that though is kind of what
got me into that situation was getting
two in my head yeah that's fair but you
haven't touched the core issue
why is there a ticker tape on the story
of your life that runs underneath
everything that goes on in your world
it says I'm a piece of crap
where does that come from
because you've done a lot of work on
relationships and you've done a lot of
work on faith and you've done a lot of
work on doing the right things and
you've probably become pretty
disciplined in your life
you have not addressed the core issue
man
you just have this meta-narrative dude
that you suck where is that from
me
um by the way this has nothing to do
with the suicide attempt
go back and listen to the call like when
you get done like this is about how you
talk about your wife you talk about your
daughter
you think you're a burden to them
where does that come from why do you
think they are worse off because you're
in their life
because it's not true where does that
come from
I would say
it's a great question and I'm trying to
think through hold on
you are have created a force field
around your life with your intellect
and your ability to construct and
deconstruct ideas and situations and
people and religions and all that stuff
and it provides you a force field from
having to do one scary thing that is
actually feel something
so I don't want you thinking about it
and going down what's the right words
and what's the right thing
where did you get this story
you know the answer
um I I would say did you grow up in a
super religious household
I did not quite the opposite I mean my
I'm the only believer in my family uh it
was never something
I mean I never heard about any of it
until like I didn't hear about face or
um Christianity until high school so
I didn't find out until after the fact
that my parents disagreed with that and
didn't buy into that
um I'm also a middle child
uh for what that's worth but I am too
we're all kind of a little bit messed up
a little bit messed up uh here's the
thing here's the thing
cynicism
is a bulletproof vest that you put on
to head into your day
so that you don't have to feel
and it protects you from
shame
protects you from looking at that
nine-year-old little girl and being
scared about the economy or whether
China is going to invade or whatever the
news is telling you the next tragedy du
jour is
and there's a helpless feeling when you
hold your first baby
there's a helpless feeling that nobody
talks about
because it's either Andrew Tate flexing
or it's it's
this passive nonsense and in the middle
is the rest of us
who's newly married three or four years
in and this woman
hugs us on a couch
with a sense they lean on you
with a weight
that says I put my hands in your life
that has nothing to do with who's making
the most money in the house how you're
splitting up chores it's just a
responsibility that every man I know
feels it's some shape form or fashion
and it's really really heavy and our
dads didn't tell us that
yeah and it's I would say it's it's
pretty exhausting like because I don't
want to be cynical like I don't
I don't want that for my the these women
in my home no no bro I don't want it for
you
that too do I want it for you and if you
do things for them like that all the
time
at some point you run out of gas
which is why it's so counterintuitive
when I tell you the path out of this is
you have to say as an identity a new
identity for Colin I reject cynicism I'm
not going there it's a waste of my time
and it destroys me and my family
if you were to ask me of what I think is
the most profound psychological finding
of the last hundred years I could talk
to you about Amos diversky you talked
about Kahneman all the greats
but it would come back to one thing that
has impacted me personally the most and
that's from Martin Seligman
who does a lot of work on positive
psychology
and basically this the study of
psychology has always been what's the
pathology what's wrong with somebody
and Martin came in and goes why don't we
look at what's right there's a whole
bunch of things that are right with
people but there's just one or two
things that people are struggling with
what if we spend our energy working on
what's right and through some of his
experiments what he came to to uncover
that has greatly impacted me is this
we all thought psychologically speaking
for a hundred or two hundred or maybe
maybe thousands of years I haven't dug
into it that far but that certain people
were EOS they're just born that way
and certain people were just like ah hey
joyful people and the rest of us fell on
some sort of spectrum
what segment comes back and suggests is
that optimism is a learned behavior
pessimism and cynicism is a learned
behavior and when anyone says the words
learned behavior to me
I exchange learned behavior with choice
I choose to look at the most Cosmic
negative way I can look at something
or we all know people
is who someone goes hey man the economy
is about to go down and they're like oh
my gosh it's because of the Republicans
and the Democrats and we've got to get a
freezer and we got to plan a garden it's
all coming down and there's those
friends that we have that like there's
going to be a recession and they smile
real big and they're like dude we're
gonna make millions
that's that's not an operating system
it's a learned behavior it's a choice
and so by you saying I reject cynicism
I'm going to choose optimism I'm going
to choose joy and by the way
um optimism I mean cynicism and
pessimism that's that's our cultural
that's our culture's um wisdom these
days
you and me could probably go round and
round over drinks and have a blast and
you would probably run circles around me
deconstructing Faith because you've been
there
in cynicism and pessimism and oh yeah
what about this what about this that is
what our culture calls wisdom these days
and I wholeheartedly reject that it's
nonsense
it's nonsense and so
the only path forward
number one you gotta write 22 year old
call in a letter and forgive him for
scaring you to death
you gotta you gotta let that dude off
the hook man
he made a rash decision he freaked out
he has heartbroken on Easter morning he
was exhausted and didn't want to hurt
anymore
and he reached over and grabbed the one
thing he had which is insulin pump and
tried to walk out on it
right
yeah and then you got to look at 29 year
old 28 year old Colin and say dude
we're gonna practice optimism
and we're going to reject
cynicism and that means
you can be optimistic and heartbroken
you can be optimistic and scared to
death you can be optimistic and really
frustrated
but that's different than feeling like
my wife when you hold your baby or you
hold your wife and you think I'm so
sorry y'all are stuck with me
um
tell me if I'm right or if I'm wrong
you're uh you're dead on
um
I I mean relate to so much of what you
just said and
there's like two types of people I can
relate to I have I I have great
that's the thing that's what's so
frustrating up to this point like like
you said how you described me as
disciplined
um doing a lot of work is absolutely
true uh I have great Community like
awesome men in my life I know but you're
the guy you're the guy in those men that
is the architect of the conversations
because that's how you that's how you
defend yourself
I mean you're just putting language to
you're absolutely right yes that's I'm
only laughing because you're dead on so
for the next three three weeks next
three months when you hang out with
those dudes you can't say anything
what you can do is when somebody says
they're they're struggling with
something
they're heartbroken about something
that you look at them and if you want to
be really intentional and weird put your
hand on their shoulder
and say hey man thank you for sharing
that period no other words
and what you're going to find is your
the identity you had as the guy with the
answers and the guy with all of the oh
yeah what up because here's the deal
guys like you and me who build these
webs of
of uh of intelligence to protect
ourselves we don't have any thoughts of
Our Own
we don't have any values of our own
because our only value is making sure
you can't ever sit still on your value
because I've got a way to pull it apart
yeah and I'm a few years ahead of you
and I'm telling you you hit a brick wall
because when you're anchorless and you
have no value Anchored In other than I'm
the smartest guy in the room or I can
pull this guy's argument apart or I can
pull this guy's argument apart
then a nine-year-old nine month old
little girl looks at you and says daddy
what's right
your wife looks at you and says hey can
we create
a set of values for this home
and your inside knows my only value is
well they're dumb and that's not
something you can build a home on
and so practicing optimism
practicing and that sounds all Kumbaya
here's what I mean
hey quit watching the news just turn it
off just stop
number two read fiction for a while you
need to detox from
dun dun dun turn podcast off for a while
even mine and mine's incredible by the
way just kidding but you got a detox
from info because what you do is you
listen to an hour podcast like this you
take two of the lines and then you use
that to spread amongst right is that
fair
yeah okay
instead start practicing feeling
valuable just because your presence just
because you're there
and what you're going to be surprised is
that people value Colin because Colin
showed up not because Colin listens to
obscure podcasts that nobody's heard of
yeah
and can wrap circles around penal
substitutionary atonement and all the
like you can just do all that right you
know all those things and they don't man
Colin has value
the only path forward manage you gotta
learn to feel and this is the pot
talking of the kettle here
I'm practicing this as we speak it's
hard
do you have can I
I've been on
antidepressants since
that a suicide attempt
and
there's days where I I'll forget to take
them and I just like ball like I I it's
like this whole world is opened up a
Feeling
and
I
I'm also afraid to go off of them though
yeah
it's been seven years
yeah I took sleep medications for seven
years six seven years and I was
terrified to get off terrified
and I spent months being unable to sleep
scary
totally get him
totally get it
what I would tell you is at some point
you sit down with your doctor and with
your counselor or psychiatrist and you
say
I'm ready to enter into a new phase of
my life
where
I need to come up with some scaffolding
some structure
and we're gonna do this real real real
slow
but I want to learn to feel
and I want to learn some strategies for
feeling
and
that means they're going to have some
really clear suicide plan in case that
that feeling of that urge comes up again
and you're gonna have to commit before
me and your doctors and practitioners
and your friends and family and God that
you will call you will not take your
life
you commit that
oh absolutely yeah I mean I have I have
too much to live for you're 100 exactly
so they're going to come up with some
strategies and plans and then it's just
a stair-stepped process cool we'll
reduce it by this much for this period
of time
and we're gonna practice it we're gonna
feel it and yes you're gonna have
periods of of time when you just weep
openly
that stuff stored in your body it
doesn't go anywhere
there's gonna be periods where you were
super disciplined and now you can't get
out of bed it's gonna be all that's
going to be part of the thing
part of your healing process if that's
what you choose to do but you're gonna
have to this is the Cornerstone you're
gonna have to have people in your corner
you're going to have to start trying to
over intellect intellectualize
everything you're gonna just gonna have
to be honest about what you feel
Zafir
it's fair I have one
scary stupid question that I want to ask
you out loud like is obvious
it's you don't think it's too late for
me to change my
Outlook
I went to a trauma counselor for the
first time about four months ago
and everything in my life is different
because there's stuff I've never talked
about ever
and I'm in my 40s
and I have a seven-year-old little girl
and a 13 year old boy and a woman I've
been married to for 21 years
no
and I've sat with 70 year olds
who decided to change their life and
start lifting weights and start eating a
little different and call their kids and
they say I'm sorry
with the time we got left can we control
alt delete and do something new
I do not believe in the phrase it's too
late but I want you to hear the order of
this
start with your wife
take her out to a dinner take her out to
breakfast and say
I'm getting ready to enter into healing
part two
we've been on maintenance for seven
years we feel good we feel safe we feel
secure we've got a beautiful kid we've
got a great marriage we're heading into
part two and part two is gonna be rough
it's gonna be bumpy
I'd be willing to bet you money if we
had another hour to talk you had some
stuff going on in your childhood that is
gnarly
you're gonna have to deal with that or
it will deal with you
part of the journey in the next
conversation after your wife is you're
going to sit down with your doctor
or your counselor or both in a perfect
world and you're going to let everybody
know
I need some coaches and I need some
physician and some ringside support
because I'm heading into the middle of
the Ring here
and we're going to stair step off this
stuff I'm going to practice feeling I'm
going to practice learning I'm going to
practice crying and holding that I'm
going to practice feeling joy for the
first time in a long time I'm going to
practice feeling embarrassment and shame
I'm going to practice all those things
over the next one two dude this is a
this is a multi-year journey you're on
all good
just like lifting weights man
some days you have good workouts some
days you don't but over the long haul
you get healthier you feel better and
you can do so much more
I cannot put into words how proud of you
I am Colin
this is what bravery and courage and
just straight gangster looks like
a dad his little baby girl and his wife
and Dad looking in the mirror saying I'm
worth being well so that I can show up
for these too
with all I got
I'll walk with you brother every step of
the way here holler at me anytime I'm
proud of you